well i'm here in la viv ukraine in what
used to be a sporting equipment store
but which has now been transformed into
a volunteer humanitarian center which is
run by a ukrainian ngo called help the
front and as you can see they've got
their hands full they were set up back
in 2014 following the russian annexation
of crimea but they have never been
busier since the russian invasion of
ukraine and of course you know as you
can see they're packed full of boxes a
lot of these containing badly needed
medical supplies these medical kits with
tourniquets and bandages
but they say what they really need is
tactical equipment so
these thermal imaging cameras this
little guy can see body heat through
bushes for example up to one and a half
kilometers away
drones body armor equipment that
ukrainian soldiers desperately need on
the front lines in this collection right
here was in fact recently sent
from canada provided by a group called
maria aid that was just recently set up
by members of the canadian military on a
volunteer basis who previously served
here in ukraine as part of operation
unifier many of the individuals that
they knew on the front lines were
reaching back out to them to say
we need gear we need specialized
equipment we need body armor and helmets
and drones
and so these individuals these
volunteers decided to come together and
form an organization that organization
maria aid was set up in response to the
russian invasion of ukraine and has
since grown to include canadian
paramedics firefighters and ukrainian
canadians from all walks of life they're
now working to send this desperately
needed tactical equipment here to
levieve where it is then distributed to
the front lines jeff semple global news
in la viv ukraine